[Music]
so there's a new ritual that lots of us
share right now checking our temperature
to see if we have a fever and it's
understandable fever is a common symptom
of kovat 19 but if you're hoping your
temperature is a nice 98.6 degrees or 37
Celsius you might learn something new
about yourself ninety seven point two
five ninety eight point two ninety seven
point one very low I okay it turns out
98.6 degrees Fahrenheit isn't really the
ideal or normal body temperature there's
really no such thing but temperature
could still tell us a lot about our
health and about the spread of kovat 19
[Music]
the number ninety eight point six mostly
came from a nineteenth century German
researcher named Karl Reinhold August
Linder
he claimed to crunch the numbers of more
than a million temperature readings from
thousands of patients and he arrived at
the number of 98.6 that number has stuck
around ever since
but person-to-person it's kind of
meaningless we asked her co-workers to
take their own readings and this is what
normal temperature looks like for us
ninety five point eight three ninety six
point seven which seems low I'm a cold
cold man maybe a little bit it's fine I
guess
Moodle ish himself knew that body
temperature varied he recorded a healthy
range from ninety seven and a quarter to
ninety nine and a half in his subjects
other studies have shown that
temperature can differ noticeably across
age gender size and race and modern
research points to a much lower number
of around ninety eight that squares with
our very informal staff average we're
around ninety seven point five you know
that or my thermometers broken no no
what's more you yourself don't have one
body temperature you have a range our
team all took their readings at 10:00
a.m. but if you took yours a bunch over
the course of a day you'll see it change
most people our coolest in morning and
warmest in the early evening it's a
reflection of your body's natural
rhythms your digestion hormone
production cognition and more here's
what my temperature looks like
throughout the day
other bodily cycles like ovulation can
cause small swings in temperature - and
different parts of you are different
temperatures under the tongue armpit
forehead and rectal readings are all
likely to be unique point is there are
tons of variables we can be many
temperatures all at once
all the time and still be perfectly
healthy but being sick is another story
so I spoke with a couple people who are
connecting some interesting dots between
temperature variation and an illness
like Ovid 19 when you get sick many of
your body's natural predictable rhythms
start to destabilize your temperature
might fluctuate more erratically and it
might crank up above your natural range
that's your body triggering a fever to
make itself less hospitable to viruses
or bacteria in other words your body
temperature gets anomalous that's
trouble for you but for people tracking
kovat it's crucial data one effort is
kinsa a company that tracks the spread
of infectious disease using fevers kinsa
cells a smart thermometer that sends
your temperature back to the company
every time you take it Kenseth says they
have about a million thermometers in
circulation and with all that data
they've built a real-time health weather
map it shows possible hot spots of Kovan
counties with more fever than flu season
would explain let's take our real-time
signal and remove the expected value
cold and flu what's left over is a
residual that residual is atypical and
in this particular analysis a typical
fever clusters things that you would not
expect what we found since that point is
that there's a very high correlation
between our hot spots in koban 19 cases
the work is not peer reviewed yet and
some experts question how reliable it
can be with only a million thermometers
their user base could also be biased by
race or class or other factors but
Kenseth still thinks it can tease out
some interesting trends like the effect
of social distancing here's their look
at miami-dade County
the middle of March in nine days the
percent of people with a fever more than
doubled and around the 17th and 18th
they started implementing the closure of
bars so it starts going down other
researchers are taking a different tack
looking for clues and body temperature
that might predict a fever before it
starts one study out of UCSF will
collect temperature and other health
data from participants by using a smart
ring the Rings can measure small changes
in body temperature every minute the
question is can tiny temperature rhythms
predict a brewing infection like Kovan
and so we can pick up with great
reliability those ultradian rhythms
those within a day rhythms that are the
frequency that tend to tell us about how
stable ER your hormones pulsing along
how synchronized are they inside of you
it's early days for the study but one
smart ring user who tested positive for
kovat has already shared some
interesting data the temperature rhythms
that I was seeing within the day start
to sort of destabilize and amplify
before they have a fever right up to
about five days beforehand the whole
system looked like it was sort of
increasingly like a teeter totter before
they had a favorite before they felt
sick again that's just one patient but
with enough data the team hopes to build
an algorithm that can sniff out kovat
via rhythms like these we will be
publishing the findings we will be
putting out you know competitions or
calls for sort of hackathon II things of
like get everybody in the room let's get
this as good as we can possibly get it
this is really just how big of a
difference can we make how quickly to
get this into service in the coming
months while we take our temperatures
every minute like maniacs we're going to
hear a lot more about the effort to
track and predict kovat 19 scientists
will learn more about how the human body
regulates itself and responds to disease
and along the way we might let go of
some assumptions about what's normal and
healthy obsessing about 98.6 is really
false precision right everybody should
have a nice daily rhythm of their
temperature the only time your
temperature is
constant is when you're dead and it's
room temperature so thinking about the
patterns of change rather than the
absolute number is much more important
okay
one get out of there 1.1.1